can't believe i'm saying this but your  checkup is completely clean you're in  perfect health all right last question i  have for you is whether or not you'd  like to be an organ donor  uh what would that entail you know and  when you die maybe we would harvest your  organs and give them to a little girl  who's been in a car accident or maybe a  mother who went through a complicated  pregnancy perhaps give them to a doctor  who needs to finish his monster  a little girl  in need uh no not the mother one the  last one the one about me finishing my  monster  i'm working on a monster  the no you don't like helping little  girls no i don't want to help you make a  monster finish my monster it's almost  done  sorry he's almost done  no  okay sorry to hear that  is this a current address we have for  you yeah yeah  great great great great great great  guess who's getting mauled by my monster  as soon as i find a kneecap two kidneys  and a big old dick  you